thank you
bars hibernate solar activate Falcon
classical Silver Strike and type of free
flow Agave pixie has our NBC code
ignites Olympia radio
Jango Cherry Pie and wsgi class Hammer
web spear red beam turbo gives Albatross
aquarium selenium
[Music]
great work
together
a site called tapestry Maverick and JSP
Barracuda akarama groovy on Grails
intercalon Interstate Cascade and
hibernate
jdbc Ruby on Rails Jasmine Doctrine Java
forms engine active record D3 Dapper and
velocity time Leaf top link pyramid
rethink or a recommitory and mojito
foreign
[Music]
morning
NBC Ken dots and otbc and Tempo Java
server faces entity spaces cappuccino
spec flow polymer jdo Google
JavaScript JD
what else do I have to say
quality
type boilerplate jQuery animates
mustache Tempo ionic and Allegro
bootstrapped back both running on an
iPhone mobile app going live built-in
HTML5 angular scriptaculous react Redux
knockout Ember does anyone remember just
like in the browser Wars I explore and
that's great for low Dash versus
underscore and I could take it anymore
what
what are you want to use
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen of the class of 17.
use flat screens
if I could offer you only one tip for
the future
flat screens would be it
the benefits of flat screens have been
proved in Hollywood
whereas the rest of my advice has no
basis more reliable than my own
Meandering experience
I will dispense this advice now
enjoy the confidence and optimism of
Greenfield projects oh never mind you'll
not appreciate the confidence and
optimism of Greenfield till things start
going wrong but trust me when you
finally ship you'll look back at the
code you wrote and recall in a way you
can't grasp now how simple everything
seemed and how productive you really
were
your code is not as bad as you imagine
don't worry about changing database
providers or worry but know that every
company who used an orm in case they
needed to switch databases never
actually did it the real problems in
your projects are the dependencies you
can't control the engineer who
unexpectedly leaves your team at 4 pm on
some idle Tuesday
learn one thing every day that scares
you
optimize don't reformat other people's
code bases don't put up with people to
reformat yours rebase don't get obsessed
with Frameworks sometimes they help
sometimes they hurt it's the user
experience that matters and the user
doesn't care how you created it
remember the retweets you receive forget
the flame bait if you succeed in doing
this tell me how
keep your old hard drives throw away
your old network cards
refactor
don't feel guilty if you don't
understand F sharp some of the most
productive Junior developers I've worked
with didn't know F sharp some of the
best systems Architects I know still
don't
write plenty of tests
be kind to your keys you'll miss them
when they're gone
maybe you have a degree maybe you don't
maybe you have an open source project
maybe you don't maybe you wrote code
that flew on the space shuttle maybe you
worked on Microsoft SharePoint whatever
you do keep improving and don't worry
where your next gig is coming from
there's a big world out there and
they're always going to need good
Developers
look after your brain don't burn out
never be scared to take a break it is
the most powerful computer you will ever
own
launch
[Music]
of no users but your own QA team
have a plan even if you choose not to
follow it do not read the comments on
YouTube they will only make you feel
angry
cash your package dependencies you never
know when they'll be gone for good
read your log files they're your best
source of information and the first
place you'll notice if something's
starting to go wrong
understand that languages come and go
and it's the underlying patterns that
really matter work hard to fill the gaps
in your knowledge because the wiser you
get the more you'll regret the things
you didn't know when you were young
code in 86 assembler once but stop
before it makes you smug
code and Visual Basic ones but stop
before it makes you stupid
read accept certain inalienable truths
your code has bugs you will miss your
deadlines and you too might end up in
management and when you do you'll
fantasize that back when you're a
developer code was bug free deadlines
were met and developers tuned their
database indexes
tune your database indexes
don't deploy your code without testing
it maybe you have a QA team maybe you
have integration tests you never know
when either one might miss something
Don't Mess too much with your user
interface
or by the time you ship it will look
like a karaoke Booth be grateful for
open source but be careful whose code
you run
sharing code is Noble but there's more
to it than taking bits of your projects
folder putting a readme file on them and
hoping if you upload it to GitHub
someone else will come along and fix all
your problems
but trust me on the flat screens
[Music]
foreign
to him
HTML
[Music]
baby
no trackers
to ignore
pain of Freedom no hackers
the occasional 404
they hating
what I do
[Music]
understand
break it down remember to Escape
[Music]
please mail
them
[Music]
changed
but it's really just
[Music]
foreign
how are you all doing out there
and welcome to uh the last session
before the party which is always the one
where I know a couple of you like come
on get the thing done then we can go and
have the beers and stuff so uh thank you
for coming to WhatsApp web3 and Wordle
evolving a digital Society now uh we're
gonna start off with a you know nice
easy trivial question we're not going to
get into anything too deep
is internet access a fundamental human
right
on February the 28th this year this guy
wrote a letter to this guy does anyone
know who these people are
the one on the left this is uh Michaela
federov he is the vice prime minister
the Deputy Prime Minister of Ukraine
he's also the Ukrainian Minister for
digital transformation he ran the
digital campaign that President
zielinski ran when he was elected and
the guy on the right is a Quran mabi who
is the chief executive and president of
icann the internet Consortium for
assigned cooperation for assigned names
and numbers and if you have read the
news at all this year one I'm sorry
there is therapy we will drink
afterwards but there is a lot of very
heavy [__] going on the content of this
letter on the 28th of February was
basically uh Mr federov saying to Mr
mabi please could you help us by uh the
following sanctions targeting the
Russian federation's access to the
internet could you revoke the domains
are you fair and Su which is the Soviet
Union did you know the Soviet Union had
top level domain today I learned
contribute to revoking the SSL
certificates for all of the above
mentioned domains and shut down the DNS
route servers in Saint Petersburg and
Moscow now
I have been to Ukraine many many times
and I have witnessed firsthand the
digital transformation that was taking
place there over the last few years and
it's quite astonishing I've talked to
startups there I've been to Tech hubs in
Odessa and in Kiev and I think the
Ukrainian Minister for digital
transformation sounds like somebody who
knows what he's doing at this time in
the UK we had a minister for digital
transformation who went to a meeting
with Microsoft and asked them when they
were going to ban the algorithms
so you know I think Michaela federov one
knows exactly what he's asking for and
two he probably knew that they were
going to say no because the reply came
back very quickly from icann saying we
sympathize and you have our support but
we are not going to do the things that
you ask for I can has been built to
ensure that the internet works not for
its coordination role to be used to stop
it from working I can it's kind of it's
the closest thing the internet has to a
police force they're the people who
allocate the domain names and they
manage the top level DNS root servers
and this kind of stuff
but that wasn't the only letter that
Michaela federov sent in February he
also wrote a letter to these people
now you have probably never heard of
these people they don't own any servers
they don't own any cables they don't own
any mobile phone towers or
infrastructure and if they disappeared
the internet would stop working
not immediately the next couple of weeks
it would probably be fine and then some
of you might realize that you could no
longer send email to certain companies
who you deal with some websites would uh
become unavailable and you're not
entirely sure why and eventually the
internet as we know it would cease to
operate now when we talk about
connecting to the internet
we tend to think of this there's a big
cloud of magical data up in the sky and
we connect to it using little lines with
arrows on the end and we've all seen
these kinds of diagrams devices connect
to the internet and uh for most of us
this is true because we are very very
small and we are very insignificant and
we have our phone and our tablet and our
laptop and we want to connect to the
internet where the good stuff is but if
you are big if you are a major European
cable communications provider if you are
Microsoft if you are Amazon if you own a
terabit cable that runs across the
bottom of the Atlantic Ocean for example
you do not connect to the internet you
are the internet you live in the cloud
that's where you do your thing and the
rest of us kind of rely on you to help
us get stuff from here to here if you
own a lot of cable you don't pay for
internet access what you do is you find
your nearest internet exchange point and
you say right we're gonna run on our
cable in there
and we're going to see who else has
cable running in here and then we are
going to talk to them and we are going
to set up what are called peering
agreements and this is what rape do in
the UK is they facilitate those
agreements Amazon says to Microsoft yeah
we'll carry your network if you carry
hours and then telenor says well we got
a bunch of cables so we'll carry yours
if you carry ours so when I send you an
email or we do a zoom call or you know
we're playing Far Cry or something the
packets that are connecting me to you
are actually flowing through all of
these companies telecoms providers
academic research institutes and they
don't know about it and they generally
don't care about it because transparency
is part of that pairing agreement
there's like anything you send us we'll
send out the other side ripe is one of
five Regional internet registries ripe
NCC covers Europe and uh most of uh well
as far east as the the tips of Russia
over there there is uh Aaron North
America
there is lachnick which is Latin America
and Caribbean there is afrenic which
covers Africa and there is apnic Asia
Pacific and between them they control
pretty much not control they facilitate
almost all of the internet traffic that
exists anywhere in the world and they
sent a letter back to Michaela federov
he basically said can you please cut
Russia off the internet and they sent
back and said no
um we're not going to do that and
further We Believe internet number
resource registrations should not be
used as a means to enforce political
outcomes doing so would have serious
implications for the internet not just
in the Russian Federation but in the
rest of the world so
can we cut somebody off the internet
even if they're being really awful and
we really really want to probably not
because the two organizations who have
the power to do that realize that would
be an incredibly dangerous path to go
down so it would appear that internet
access is a de facto right but what
about any kind of theoretical or legal
basis for it well Tim bernersley creator
of the World Wide Web is now campaigning
on exactly this issue he spoke to an
event at the European Parliament late
last year where he was outlining his
vision for an internet where human
rights access to that internet is a
guaranteed human right we need
governments companies Civil Society
citizens to work together now to create
a future where internet access is
understood and realized as a basic human
right so we've got icann saying we're
not going to disconnect you we've got
ripe NCC we've got Tim berners-lee
saying this now the universal
Declaration of Human Rights
this goes back to 1948 and for some
reason they didn't put Wi-Fi access in
it when they wrote it in 1948 but the
people who drafted this were pretty
clever and they're like stuff might
change you know and so the articles that
I think are applicable here Article 19
everyone has the right to freedom of
opinion and expression this right
includes freedom to hold opinions
without interference and seek receive
and impart information and ideas through
any media and regardless of Frontiers
and if you don't think that quite
clinches it there's article 27.1
everyone has the right freely to
participate in the cultural life of the
community to enjoy the Arts and share in
scientific advancement and its benefits
so I think there is a pretty strong both
a de facto and a theoretical case for
internet access being a human right
but what do we mean internet access what
is this thing that we're arguing about
whether you have the right to it or not
well
I think it would look something like
this I think it would be the right to
connect to the network and be assigned
an IP address for as long as you need
one
if you transmit a properly formed and
correctly addressed packet across the
internet and if your destination address
exists that packet will reach its
destination and if anybody else anywhere
on the internet sends a properly formed
packet that is correctly addressed to
you that packet will be delivered and it
logically follows on that if this is
something we are going to try and
enshrine as a right nobody should be
allowed to interfere with that traffic
while it is in transit now
let's imagine for one second that uh the
company who managed the highways decide
they're not they don't have enough money
they want to get in on this free market
capitalism they've read about and so
they start shopping around and they're
like hey I've got a good idea let's see
if we can do some partnership deals so
the highways agency they get a BMW and
they say hey how much money will you
give us to give all your BMW drivers
extra speed limit and BMW go I don't
know half a billion euros that sounds
like that boom there you go BMWs can do
170 and then the Audi people are like
hey we'll do that we'll pay double what
they paid Audi gets 170. Ford come along
they're like well 150 uh Toyota are like
we'll we'll pay a little bit but our
cars don't go that fast so 90k is
probably good enough for us and then
just to make this look special they say
everyone else 50 kilometers an hour
that's your limit and then finally the
uh petrogas chemical companies come
along and they're like um yeah while
we're doing this we'll give you a bunch
of money if you ban electric cars cause
they're really putting a dent in our
profits and there it is we have a
wonderful free market capitalist freeway
system where if you want to go really
really fast you have to buy a BMW and
put Petrol in it because the people who
sell the BMWs and the people who sell
the petrol control the people who
control the speed limits this sounds
like a nightmare right
there are companies everywhere who want
to do this to the internet right now
in the United States most domestic
Broadband access is dominated by four
huge companies Comcast atnt Verizon
Charter Communications and there are
large parts of the US where you do not
have a choice if you live in a Comcast
neighborhood or a Comcast District you
have Comcast or you have dial-up that's
it there is no free market capitalism
there is de facto Monopoly capitalism at
work here and 2007 a bunch of folks in
the US who are paying for internet
access through Comcast they notice that
some of their traffic was not going as
fast as it should some files they were
downloading from a pirate website they
found and they complained to the Federal
Communications Commission and they said
we are paying for 26 megabits and we're
not getting it
and the FCC which is the branch of the
United States government that
administers Communications radio
wireless and eventually the internet
they turn around to Comcast and they
said you need to stop throttling your
users traffic that is illegal and
Comcast said all right yep fine whatever
you say FCC they took the throttles off
they turned around and they sued the
government and they said you do not have
permission or authority to tell us what
to do now this dragged on for a couple
of years it was the first time that this
issue of network neutrality had been
placed before a court of law and the DC
Circuit Court of Appeal had actually
ruled in favor of Comcast here they'd
said um we're not entirely sure that the
FCC has jurisdiction over Network
neutrality so the FCC turned around and
went right let's get it the US Open
internet order 2010 codifies as absolute
rights one transparency Network
providers will carry traffic to one end
to the other and they will not mess with
it in transit they are not allowed to
block ports they are not allowed to
block services and they are not allowed
to discriminate by for example making
Disney plus go faster than Netflix
because Disney gave them a big old you
know cash back hander this was struck
down by the Supreme Court as being
unconstitutional they said the FCC did
not have the right to interfere with
glorious free market capitalism
and that basically 2014 the day of that
judgment was the day that Network
neutrality died in the United States of
America
fortunately we are not in the United
States of America because the rest of
the world looked at it and went that's
really bad like did you see could that
happen here and the government of the
European Union the EU Parliament kind of
kicked into gear and went we are going
to draft and publish the EU open
internet regulation which says you have
transparency your internet provider is
not allowed to block your traffic they
are not allowed to interfere with it and
they are not allowed to unreasonably
discriminate and that was passed that is
now law in the EU and the European
economic area
um bizarrely it is one of the few bits
of European law that will still apply in
the UK after brexit because we've
thought of it first the UK had an
internet transparency act in 2010 which
actually was the basis for the European
one now
I've been on the internet a long time
and I think Network neutrality is really
important and it's something we should
all care about but when you talk to
normal people and normal humans they're
like what network nah and they're like
well what do you think matters and
they're like I like shopping and films
and music and talking to my friends and
memes and all this kind of stuff I'm
like but that all runs on the internet
and the reason it runs on the Internet
is because we invented the World Wide
Web
and I've been on the web since the web
had a logo that looked like this
designed by Robert Calio in 1990 and I
love the web I loved building websites
when I first started I love building
websites today and one of the things
that made me fall in love with the web
was it is such a wonderful platform to
work on if you try and write a program
on a computer using
C take an example
there we go standard i o in main
princess hello world return zero and
then you're like okay please run it
and the computer goes human you are
stupid
you forgot one semicolon and therefore
your whole program is wrong and your
species is meaningless and we will take
over and you're like I hate programming
computers suck I don't want to do this
anymore and you go and work in a bank or
something but browsers no no browsers
are friendly you can feed a browser
let's make a web page so we're gonna
we're gonna write a web page and we sort
of uh we know a little bit about HTML
we're like well Pages they have a head
and so if they got ahead they probably
have a face because you know that makes
sense so this is Dylan's page and then I
got a body because there's a head and
then there's a body and then uh I've got
a heading one welcome to my web page
that's fine and font color equals red
because I want red text so that it's
it's multimedia and interactive and I'm
going to put a line break and font color
blue so look I've got red and I got blue
and I'm going to put an image on here
here's my cat this is this is Mac image
source equals cat name is Matt because
that's his name and he likes snacks I
like SQL snack and then I'm going to
close the body and then if it's got a
head and a body it probably needs feet
right so I'm going to have feet and and
then I'm going to close it and I'm in a
hurry because I'm really excited I want
to see so I actually didn't close htlm
instead of HTML
um get your phone out scan that QR code
that works
there's no syntax error your browser
doesn't go invalid markup at line zero
it's like uh yeah all right well I I
understand most of this this is what
renders this is what that thing looks
like because browsers are a wonderful
example of something called postel's law
this is John postel John wrote the
specification for tcpip which is the
transport layer that drives most of the
internet and apostles law says be
conservative in what you send and be
liberal in what you accept if you are
sending data to another system don't
send weirdo data to prove how impressive
you are and if you are receiving data
from another system be nice do the best
thing you can try your best to work out
okay this isn't exactly 100 spec
compliant but I can see what they're
trying to do here so let's assume that's
what they're trying to do now there is a
wonderful example of this principle in
real life which has nothing to do with
the internet and Technology
in 1975 the United States and the Soviet
Union launched a joint space mission
Apollo Sawyers they were going to launch
a soyuz capsule from baikonur which is
in what's now Kazakhstan launch an
Apollo capsule from Florida they were
going to Rendezvous in orbit and the
commanders were going to share a
historic handshake through the airlock
and one of the protocols for this
mission
they had a whole bunch of problems
nothing was compatible different
electrical systems different units
because Soviet Union used the metric
system and America still went to space
in feet and inches and foot pounds of
torque
apparently
um and they had a language barrier
because the cosmonauts all spoke Russian
and the Americans the astronauts they
all spoke English
and they decided early on the best way
to avoid misunderstandings is the
Americans had to speak Russian and the
Russians had to reply in English so you
were always speaking the language that
you'd just done the three-month crash
course in and you were always listening
to the reply in the language you grew up
with because the potential for
misunderstanding this is the historic
handshake this is Colonel Tom Stafford
and the Soviet Commander Alexi leonov
there is no way Alexi leonov is going to
know an English word that Tom Stafford
has never heard before and vice versa
and so the protocol as a side effect
meant they had to be conservative in
what they were sending because they only
had three months worth of Crash Course
vocabulary and they were doing their
best to be as tolerant and as patient as
an understanding as they could be and so
when I was you know sat there bashing
away on Internet Explorer version 2 and
trying to figure out how HTML worked now
this is me you know I'm Tom Stafford
trying to speak Rush and the browser is
being a Lexi leonov going yeah that's
nonsense but I think I know what you're
getting at now this principle of being
conservative in in what you send and uh
liberal in what you accept
there have been points in the history of
the web where people were not
conservative in what they did there were
websites everywhere that even to get the
home page to load you had to install
this plugin and that plug-in and this
thing and Flash and macro media and
Shockwave and this Java applet and all
this weird crap that doesn't work
anymore but uh
get your phone out again and go to this
URL
now uh how many of you all here is there
anyone in the room who was born after
Jar Jar Binks was a thing like anyone
here is like you know 2021 yeah we gotta
we got a couple of hands so the code to
this website
is older than you
because uh I wrote the site in 1997 When
I Was An undergraduate at University and
I kind of played around with it for a
year and then I got bored and uh the
site looks like it looks like this it's
my collection of 3D models of Star Wars
spaceships because uh I was a really
cool guy who you know
um and I haven't touched the code I have
not modified anything if you go to that
URL right now you are looking at HTML
that I wrote in textpad in 1997 looks
like this it still works
and the reason it still works on devices
that did not even exist when I wrote it
is I didn't use Flash I didn't use
plugins I didn't use weird extensions
and hacks I was like I'm just going to
do this with the HTML that kind of the
browsers support natively I loved making
websites in the 90s because you could do
stuff like this that yeah now it looks
kind of a little bit quaint and quirky
we'd never done anything like that
before and I love building websites
today because here in 2022 browsers are
awesome like you can plug a midi piano
into your web browser and use it to do
things in JavaScript we've got 3D
rendering we've got camera access we've
got microphone access we've got an
accelerometer API so you can build a web
page that knows if you've dropped it on
the floor you know how awesome is this
as a platform the problem is
there are two fundamental frustrations
as a developer I love the web as a
consumer as a Creator as somebody who
lives and breathes and does business on
the web it kind of sucks and that's
because of two things I think they
didn't really cover very well when we
designed the standards that run the web
money and identity now it's not that I
didn't think about it the people who
created HTML and HTTP they put in
username password authentication they
put in web authenticate headers if you
have a look at the original spec for the
hypertext transfer protocol version 1.1
June 1999 this is one month after jar
jar and they've got this code 402
payment required reserved for future use
well it's been 23 years folks
when are you gonna do something with it
now
fundamentally I think there are three
models of Commerce that exist on the web
and two of them we've pretty much got
right the first is mail order use the
web you browse the catalog you're like
add to basket you put in your MasterCard
number and the next day you get a brown
package from Amazon cardboard Center and
you're like and you open it and you're
like yeah I'm gonna order more stuff
um anyone ever drunk Amazon where you
buy things you don't remember buying and
then like stuff arrives at your house
you're like ah drunk me bought me
presents this is great but you know we
had mail order before you could order
things over the phone or buy fax or by
writing letters so this was just taking
an existing model of Commerce and
transplanting it onto a new platform and
then we have downloads where it's you
know have you really bought anything
like you've got a license and you've got
a stream of bits but yesterday you
didn't have the movie and now you've
given them a little bit of money and
you've downloaded a file and now you've
got the movie so you can watch the movie
and we as a society have mostly become
pretty comfortable with that we can buy
music we can buy media we can buy ebooks
and you're not getting anything physical
but you then have something you didn't
have yesterday but then
there's the applications where the
content is the product is the platform
news media the kind of things where
you're not using a website to buy
anything you're using the website
because you want what's on the website
and this is where I think the modern
models of webcommerce are letting
everyone down badly
used to be you want to publish a
newspaper you're like right let's see if
we can make this thing work I'm going to
buy a load of paper and ink and all that
kind of stuff and I need something
people want to read so I'm going to hire
journalists and I will pay them by the
word or I will give them a salary they
will give me stories I put the stories
in my newspaper people buy the newspaper
to read the story and that's cool
because people are happy paying a dollar
or a Euro for a newspaper I give you
this you give me that and now I have
this thing I can read it at the end of
the day they throw it away there's no
concept of investing in newspapers and
collecting them but it was a transaction
that made sense and then you can go to
the businesses in your area you could be
like hey I got like 500 people a day
reading my paper you want to sell your
lawn mowers you've got a sale coming up
and advertising is born people start
selling you know secondhand uh they've
got a piano they don't want all this
kind of stuff and slowly this model
builds up where it's all to some extent
mutually supportive and it works and the
people who work are getting paid for
their work now
let's talk about
Wordle
towards the end of last year we started
seeing little yellow and green squares
appearing on people's Twitter feeds and
whatsapps and all those kinds of things
now Wordle was beautiful
Wordle was not a product Wordle was not
a startup Wordle was not created with
the intention of monetizing it to
leverage exponential growth Wordle was a
gift
guy called Josh Wardle who if any of you
remember a thing called the button this
was a Reddit project he put a button on
the internet and if the button didn't
get pressed for a minute the game was
over so random people had to arrive on
this page every minute and press the
button uh the button ran for three and a
half months because that's how long it
takes the internet to get bored of
pushing a button and uh the place thing
slash r slash place on Reddit that was
Josh Wardle as well and he created this
as a gift for his partner Who Loved word
games and he started circulating it just
by Word of Mouth friends of friends and
it was actually somebody on Twitter just
came up with this idea of using emoji to
communicate their their game today and
uh Josh Wardle saw it and went hey
that's brilliant I'm going to put that
in the game he added a share button and
before long by uh January this year
there were two million people every day
playing Wordle how many is two is two
million a lot
anyone know the population of Oslo
1 million so that's two oslo's every day
are playing well two million is a lot if
you sell two million records you get two
Platinum discs if two million people
went to see your movie on its opening
weekend you would smash the world box
office record by a factor of 10. 2
million is a load of people
so how much money does it cost to serve
Wordle to two million people well this
is Wordle or this was Wordle before the
New York Times bought it and screwed it
up
it was an HTML page that was two
kilobytes it was a JavaScript file of
about 188k that's the whole game
including all of the words and all of
the allowable guesses seven years worth
of daily wordal games in that one
Javascript file the wordal logo that's
not even part of the game that's just
this so when you add it to your home
screen you get a nice little button to
click on and three kilobytes of CSS so
the whole thing is less than 200k for
seven years now Wordle is a web
component it downloads onto your phone
once and then you can play it forever
doesn't phone home no tracking no
cookies no nothing
let's see how much is it going to cost
so we want to serve that to these two
million people who are playing every day
so we're going to go over to AWS and we
got uh we can get nine cents a gigabyte
on outbound transfer from an S3 bucket
so uh let's come and Bart let's do the
math we got nine cents a gigabyte that's
that per megabyte that per kilobyte 200
kilobytes for the game that much money
per player times two million players so
giving Wordle to two million people is
going to cost us 36 bucks
and we're looking at that and going well
that's I I don't know if we have that
kind of money for the most successful
mobile game that the world has seen in
years what have what if everybody on the
planet wanted to play word or what if
eight and a half billion people all
suddenly had Android phones and they all
tried to play on the same day that could
cost us as much as 120
000 we're exposed here we gotta get out
we need to start cover now let's imagine
that instead of selling wordal to the
New York Times for an undisclosed
seven-figure sum Josh Wardle gave it to
us and he said here world's yours now um
just just you know you're allowed to
charge a little bit of money but run it
as a non-profit just you know make
enough that it's covering its own cost
so uh we're gonna go and we're going to
put it in the Microsoft store and uh
Wordle is going to cost no no no no no
no no no no no no no one eight dollars
um now uh you can't charge that amount
of money
because actually Google's payment API
does let you specify amounts and microns
which is a millionth of a dollar but you
can't charge someone
um the anyone know what the lowest
valued currency in the world is other
than the British pound which is is you
know
um
the lowest valued currency is the
Iranian real and uh the official
exchange rate is about 45 000 Rials to
the dollar so that is about one Iranian
real so we could say all right well if
we bill in reals it's one instead of
point no no no and then we have to find
a credit card company who will take
Iranian rails that's not easy to do
either so you know what we okay we're
gonna have to make a little bit of
profit let's say it's a dollar let's say
Wordle costs a dollar for a year and we
roll out the payment system and then
it's like right now we need to okay so
we need a database of all our users so
we can keep track of who's paid and who
hasn't and then okay so we need someone
to build the database we'll hire a
database developer for that and we're
going to need a security expert because
we've got their names and addresses so
gdpr well we need to register a company
so we can report on the taxes and the
revenue which means we need to hire an
accountant and we need confirmation
emails and then we've got to find a
relay provider to send the email through
and we're gonna design the email so we
hire a ux designer and you know suddenly
we're looking at this and thinking two
million dollars is not going to be
enough like even if everyone paid us a
dollar which still this is we're going
to run out of money halfway through our
first year as a non-profit and this
is the the little Gulf of infeasibility
if you want to do stuff on the internet
and give it away for free that's easy if
you're prepared to spend you know 50
maybe a hundred Euros or Pounds or
whatever relatively small amounts of
money for people who earn it contracted
day rates then you can create wonderful
things and give them to everybody and it
costs you a little bit you know you can
get almost free not quite
and if you are prepared to sell
something that costs 20 30 50 100 100
euros those kinds of money then the web
is great but in the middle we have this
dip we have the dip of this thing is not
worth charging for because we cannot
make a profit out of charging that small
an amount of money directly
and so the developers the content
creators the artists who work in this
space they have to go right well maybe
we could put it in the App Store maybe
uh Apple can distribute this for us
because people are happy buying cheap
things on their Apple iPhone they're
like yeah 99 Cents yeah I'll take it
that's fine and Apple's like well thank
you that's 30 cents uh we can cut you
off anytime for no reason we don't have
to tell you why we did it we don't like
your face sorry you don't have a company
anymore get out bye bye and developers
go we accept the terms and conditions
because the alternative is worse than
that and there are sites that have been
working really hard to try and create
aggregated content models medium
bandcamp patreon YouTube all these kind
of sites if your content does well on
those platforms you can make money I
know people who make hundreds of
thousands of pounds a year from YouTube
channels I know bands have funded albums
through things like patreon and
Kickstarter and stuff but if you just
want to deal with your customer directly
you have a website with content on it
that's worth something and you just want
to get paid for what you do
the only option we've ever really come
up with is advertising and when I first
started building websites the way
advertising worked was you had a website
and you lied about how many visitors you
had because how is anyone going to check
they had no idea and you'd go to someone
and be like hey I have a thousand people
a day looking at my website do you want
to give me some money so I can promote
your business and your local
neighborhood Cheese Shop would go yeah
put the cheese Banner on and there we go
we got an advert and I'm getting 50
pounds a month or something and they're
getting people clicking on their advert
none of this is terribly sophisticated
and then we invent click tracking so
they can see how many requests they've
got and then the people who make the
websites they start getting a little bit
bored and they're like you know I I like
the money but I'm fed up of having to
deal with the advertisers and so Brokers
came in and originally the advertising
Brokers were people who you'd put a
little snippet of code on your website
and they'd be like right when that code
loads their site's gonna talk to our
site and we'll see which adverts we have
in the roster right now and uh we'll
we'll pick those we'll design campaigns
we'll do all this kind of stuff manually
today when you go onto a website like
this a website driven by Banner
advertising behind the scenes what
happens is that that chunk of uh if
anyone was in lemons talk yesterday
about making the web smaller this is
exactly the kind of stuff he's talking
about there's a couple of megabytes of
JavaScript in there and what it does as
I open that page that JavaScript goes
roll up roll up roll up we've got an
exciting advertising opportunity we've
got a white British man he's an Oslo for
the next couple of days he buys a lot of
Lego and guitars and he likes rock and
roll music he's into cats he's got a
bunch of stickers who wants to show him
an advert for 50 cents
40 cents 30 cents twenty ten nine eight
half a cent a quarter fraction and
eventually it gets down to some site
going uh we'll show sports bras to
anybody for point zero zero one euros
and so I get an advert for a sports bra
and I'm like well
I think I'm probably okay without that
this is how it works if you want to know
how this actually works go onto a
website like uh metro news but not as
you know it because the news you know is
true and uh you try and open their web
page and you try and click somewhere and
you can't click anywhere because you
have not accepted the cookie Banner on
there so I'm going to go down now I'm
not going to click the big green button
I'm going to click cookie settings and
I'm like okay so uh yeah that makes
sense yeah yeah okay let's let's have a
look at vendors
these are all the people who have signed
up to the auction
1494 different Brokers and conglomerates
and media companies have all said yes we
would like to participate in the selling
Dylan sports bras on the internet game
because we think that there's
opportunities in there you can go
through and take no no no no but no
one's going to do that you know we are
not going to do it and the reason this
exists the reason the advertising broker
knows that I am the white guy from
England who likes guitars and cats and
Lego and rock music and I'm going to be
in Norway for a couple of days is
because I have Googled things and I've
used Google Maps and I use Gmail and I
use TripAdvisor and TripIt and all these
different sites and every time I
interact with any of these free products
that I pay no money for I am leaving a
trail of digital Footprints and that
trail if you can get enough Footprints
you know who somebody is you know where
they were you know where they're going
you know what they're interested in you
know what to sell them you can Target
advertising at that person and this
apparently is worth an enormous amount
of money alphabet Holdings which
controls Google is a two trillion dollar
company and most of that comes from
selling advertising and selling data
used for targeted advertising and the
end result of all this is something that
I'm starting to find a little bit
worrying
the web the internet the stuff that
makes all of this work is built on open
protocols and cooperation if I want to
send you an email I have an email client
you have an email server SMTP is an open
standard we can do that that's fine it
mostly works but
Gmail
has two billion active accounts there's
eight billion people on the planet like
that's the total head count of homo
sapiens right now Google has I'm not
saying a quarter of the people in the
world use Gmail but
that's the sort of numbers we're talking
about if Gmail decides that they don't
like your face
that's two billion accounts that you
can't email anymore and I know about
this because earlier in the year Gmail
decided they didn't like my face
I don't know why they said lots of
messages were identified as spam in the
past I've owned Dylan beatty.net for 25
years I have never run a mailing list on
it because I suck at marketing I've had
it locked down with domain key
identification records and send a
protection framework the entire time
I've owned it nobody ever should have
been able to send spam from Dylan bt.net
because the only emails that go from
Dylan beatty.net are ones that I write
and I don't even type that fast but this
happened and suddenly I couldn't talk to
customers I couldn't send my girlfriend
directions on how to get to the hotel
where I was staying because anybody
using Gmail I was like sorry if you're
on Google you're going to have to go and
check your junk mail folder because uh I
don't know they just decided that they
don't like me on this now this
centralization of Open Standards away
from you know Open Standards and towards
monolithic providers I know people who
can't email Microsoft they're just like
I've given up if your company uses
Microsoft for their email I'm gonna send
you WhatsApp or something because I
can't get email through their file well
and I've given up trying to get it fixed
how many of you have slack installed
how many of you have a teams installed
and Discord and signal and telegram all
installed on all your devices all the
time because you've got that one friend
who uses telegram because they are
really really security conscious and
you've got the other friend who's also
really security conscious but they use
signal because they think telegram Zone
by the Russian mafia and you've got the
people who use Discord for their work
chat because all the others are too
corporate and you've got the people who
use teams because they work at Microsoft
or because they work with someone who
works at Microsoft and you've got to
have slack because everyone's got to
have slack because I'm in 43 different
slacks right now
um You Ever Had uh um anyone here ever
had a zoom call with someone who works
at Amazon
no you haven't because Amazon do
meetings on Amazon chime because that's
their video chat platform and if you
want to talk to the people on these
platforms you just have to suck it up
and install them and run them there is
no way that I can use my zoom to call
your teams and we can have a chat
because it's the same thing right it's
video and audio and screen sharing at
both ends but there is no standard there
is no protocol we are consolidating on
channels controlled by multinational
trillion dollar corporations now
go on Reddit at the moment reddit's a
website Reddit is a website that only
exists because of the web it's a website
aggregator and Reddit is now owned by a
Conde Nast Publications who own Vogue
and a whole bunch of other things and if
you go on reddit's website on your phone
now it says hey do you want to see this
in the Reddit app big blue open Button
yay or little gray continue in the
browser like a loser and you're like no
browser's fine and it's this page looks
better in the app and you're like no I'm
good actually the app has unlimited cats
well I'm a dog person oh no the app has
unlimited dogs
um and then certain kinds of content uh
for some reason Windows error messages
are considered not safe for work on
Reddit because I tried to open one and
it said yeah you'd need to use the
Reddit app to browse this anonymously
because you don't want anyone knowing
you've been looking at blue screens of
death on there now why do you think
Reddit is so desperate that you don't
use their website
it's because one if you're using that
app they can track you they can track
where you click everything you open
everything you do you can't install an
ad blocker on the Reddit app if you're
using a web browser you can block ads on
the Reddit app you do not have that
control now last month uh this guy Felix
krauser he published this really
interesting thing it's called
inappbrowser.com and what it does you
share a link to this on Facebook or
YouTube Anything where you have a mobile
app that opens all its web links in its
own browser which runs as part of that
app if you click a link on Facebook
mobile it doesn't open Safari it opens a
browser that's part of Facebook's app
and it injects JavaScript into it so
that they can track things that you
don't know they're tracking because
everything you do that started from that
link is being mediated by software that
they control now this convergence this
tendency to move away from open
platforms to closed ones is I think it's
probably inexorable I don't think we can
turn the clock back on this one and
people do it because it's convenient and
it's easy and most of the time for most
of the people it works
um I arrived in town the other day I was
like right Thursday night after the
party let's say we can find someone we
can go and listen to the music have some
beer so I went on Google and I looked up
you know rock bars in Oslo and I
scrolled down a little bit and I go past
the the trip advisor and the Yelp and
everything and I'm like oh this is good
the Rock in yeah more metal than you can
handle that sounds like my thing I click
on it it's Facebook then I have a
website anymore what's the point they
have a Facebook page that does
everything they need in terms of we're
here this is our menu these are the
bands who are playing this is the
Slipknot release party that is coming up
all this stuff is there on face now if
Facebook decide they don't like the Rock
in this company disappears from the
internet and they have no presence
anymore but that's not something they're
worrying about because the alternative
is they have to pay someone to maintain
a website and they've got to run the
WordPress and pay for this and update
that and do all the things and too many
platforms and so the convenience
overwhelms the openness and the
transparency and we end up converging on
platforms there are whole companies out
there now who run their business through
WhatsApp and yeah that you know fine it
works you can deal with customers
um in India WhatsApp for business is
absolutely massive you can book hotels
on WhatsApp you can order take out food
on WhatsApp and it's absolutely fine
unless they decide they don't like you
or or or
they accidentally screw something up
really really badly
in October last year Facebook vanished
for six hours Facebook's entire network
which took down Instagram and WhatsApp
and Facebook and uh there are people in
the world who never use anything else on
the internet Facebook install WhatsApp
those three things disappeared they
think the sky is falling first of all
there is a massive spike in DNS traffic
from everyone's browser going oh that's
interesting Facebook's not there let me
check I got the right records Dennis
Spike about a minute later there's a
massive spike in traffic on Twitter and
Linkedin are people going haha Facebook
is down it took about six hours to get
back online what had happened is uh
somebody had deleted there was a thing
called The Border Gateway protocol which
is how the hardware that makes the
internet work knows where to send the
packets when a packet gets to the edge
of my network and it needs to find its
way to your network this is way below
TCP IP and IP addresses this is the kind
of fundamental routing and plumbing that
drives the internet which Powers the web
somebody at Facebook apparently they
went to uh inspect all of the routes
into Facebook's Network and instead of
inspecting them they deleted them
now uh this was a problem people who
work for Facebook use Facebook email
addresses fb.com they use WhatsApp well
whatsapp's down because it's owned by
Facebook they use Facebook Messenger
well Facebook Messenger is down all
right I guess we'd better drive down to
the office and see if we can figure out
what's going on they can't get into the
building because the keypads on the
doors use the same authentication system
as everything else and it's down the
server that lets you open the door is
not on the internet so you can't even
get into the building where the server
is to reboot the server and reinstate
the protocols and get the thing
connected back up again eventually they
I don't know they have found someone
with a key or they found someone with an
ax and they got back in and they managed
to get Facebook and Instagram and
everything back on the web but the whole
thing was dark for about six hours
now
the way that they coordinated getting it
back online was they had to use text
messages and they had to make telephone
calls and the people who still had a
backup email address which was not a
Facebook address had to fall back to
using that Open Standards open
Communications protocols which were not
controlled by the company they all
worked for that had just accidentally
locked all of them out of their own jobs
now I was thinking about all the stuff
around the same time Facebook having to
use their old Yahoo email addresses to
get stuff back online and Dylan bt.net
getting blacklisted by Google and while
this is going on something kind of
drifted across my radar
you remember this picture at the
beginning where we color coded all the
bits of the world according to how you
get internet access there and uh there's
this little gray area down the bottom
the white continent Antarctica turns out
internet access in Antarctica is
unbelievable now if you look at the
world from below the South Pole
it looks like this Antarctica that's the
South Pole that's a South polar orbital
view now in most of the world there are
no cables running to Antarctica the only
way that Antarctica can talk to the rest
of the planet is by satellite and most
of us who use satellite internet in any
capacity we get it from the
geostationary satellite Network now
these things orbit 65 000 kilometers
above the equator
you can't see them from Antarctica
because you are so far south that they
are below the Horizon they are below the
line of sight has anyone been watching
uh For All Mankind on Apple TV
absolutely awesome show where the
Soviets were first to the moon and the
Space Race just keeps on unfolding and
you're watching and I'm sitting watching
that and thinking well that's cool and
that might happen and that's plausible
and then I get to this scene I'm like no
way are they doing video conferencing
from McMurdo Station
like you missed the episode where you
showed us how they cabled Antarctica
McMurdo Station is a real place in
Summit is about 5 000 people there in
Winter that drops to about 1 000 and if
you've seen that Kurt Russell movie the
thing it's that it's people stuck
indoors through the Antarctic winter it
is dark it is cold there is nothing to
do if you go outside you're probably
freeze to death you're like yeah it'll
be cool if we could watch Netflix and
stuff well you can't because the
satellite internet that you get in
Antarctica for about nine hours a day
you can get the interplanetary relay
Network this is the satellite Network
that is used to communicate with the
International Space Station and
occasionally with the space probes that
NASA has sent out and when it's in the
right place you can see it from McMurdo
so they get about 25 megabits of
bandwidth shared between a thousand
people when those satellites are below
the horizon
your only option is this this is the
Iridium satellite Network there are 66
iridium satellites they are in low earth
orbit about 780 800 kilometers up and
they provide satellite voice and data
services anywhere on the planet anywhere
you go you can connect to an iridium
satellite as long as you can see the sky
and you can make phone calls and you can
send email
to send one email on the Iridium
satellite Network costs about three
dollars this is not a streaming solution
for watching Netflix in Antarctica in
the winter and I was thinking about this
and I was thinking imagine if you were
in Antarctica you spent three bucks to
send someone an email and it went into
their junk mail folder because Google
doesn't like your face
and I thought hang on what if we flip
that around What If instead of the whole
you got to pay to send email and then it
goes to junk mail what if we could pay
to send email to guarantee it didn't go
to junk
what if there was a way of saying this
email is important I am going to give
you money and you are going to deliver
it do you understand on the internet
when yes now
we're gonna have to go back in time
because I think there is no way we are
going to be able to make this happen
starting from where we are now but maybe
if we'd had this idea back in the 90s
because back in the 90s everyone was
like email's amazing because it's free
but the other amazing thing that was
happening in the 90s is Nokia phones had
been invented and when you got your
phone contract in the 90s you understood
that text messages cost you money you
would get 50 free messages with your
contract and after that you would have
to pay 18 cents a text message or
something so we had almost established
this expectation that you should pay to
communicate with people so
we're going to go back in time in our
DeLorean we're going to retrofit SMTP
we're going to figure out how to fix
some of the things that we should have
got right the first time the way
internet email works is that the sender
wants to send an email so they go to the
DNS infrastructure and they go hey tell
me who handles email for dylanbeatty.net
and DNS looks up a thing called an MX
Mail Exchange record and it says oh I
send it here send it to
mail.dillanbt.net and then the sender
looks up the IP address it connects to
mail.dillan bt.net says hey I got an
email here from slash at guns
androses.com and mail.dillanbt.net goes
oh cool all right yeah send it that's
fine
is it slash
I don't know I don't know it might be
might not be we have no way there's no
protocol in here of determining whether
that is actually what it claims to be
but what if
the Sunday went hey who handles email
for Dylan Beatty guess back
mail.dillonbt.net Sun's over there hey I
got an email from slash at Guns and
Roses here is the message ID and my
server goes to the DNS hey uh I got an
email that says it's from Guns and Roses
can you check this who does DNS for Guns
and Roses it sends back oh Guns and
Roses email server it's called Beatrice
don't know why it just is
and then my server goes to them hey did
you send this
and they say yes we did and I'm like
woohoo I got actual email from slash or
more likely it says Nope and I did not
get actual email from slash I got this
guy now
all of the technology necessary to do
this has existed for 25 years it's just
that's not what we are using it for the
green padlock in your browser the SSL
certificate these days we only use those
to verify that traffic has not been
intercepted in transit
I had to get an SSL certificate in 1997
and I had to send legally notarized
paperwork confirming that I had the
right to The Domain that I was
registering the certificate for today I
could go on and I could buy uh ndcoslo
norway.com which is probably available
and then within 10 minutes I could have
an SSL certificate confirming that
that's definitely me and I am NDC Oslo
norway.com and everyone would trust it
because your browser would go green
because we just use SSL and https to
confirm Integrity we've given up on
using it to confirm identity but we
could do that the technology exists we
have certificates that trust other
certificates that trust other
certificates and we could potentially
build a way of using DNS and SSL to
prove that the domain it comes from the
person you're actually sending it to so
uh imagine I want to send you an email
and I really want you to open it in fact
like I said I'm so desperate I will pay
actual money so I'm sending big shot
lawyer from Dylan at dylanbeatt.net
these are the really important legal doc
documents this is a priority paid level
one email it's worth 50 cents
the mail provider sending mail has
always been a problem because people
want to pay for it if every email that
went out was attached to say one Cent's
worth of value running reliable SMTP
relays would be a profitable business in
its own right you wouldn't need
advertising you wouldn't need billing
it's like yeah you send us email we'll
give you 50 free emails a month after
that you have to pay you want to invite
all your friends to your birthday party
yeah it's going to cost a little more
you want to send a million people an
email advertising Viagra will pay up and
you're like actually I don't sell that
much Viagra I'm probably not interested
in using email here and all of those
micro transactions that are being sent
with the emails they just end up
accruing on the remote side I send 50
cents and my lawyer gets an email going
hey Dylan sent this and by the way if
you read it you'll get the 49 cents that
was left after imagine getting money to
read your own spam right
technically it's not that unfeasible
problem is you end up with all the
people who want to play Wordle have
emailed their dollar and suddenly play
at wordle.com's got 187 000 in it and
the account balance has suddenly done
this because it's gone viral and you're
thinking well
how are we going to get the money back
out because the question here is well
how do we turn it back into actual
dollars and maybe this is a mechanism we
would have needed to consider or maybe
we could have done what if anyone was in
my talk earlier about mobile payment
systems in Kenya maybe we're just like
you know what email is currency now you
see the thing where you go on a slack
and you want to sign in and instead of a
password it just sends a thing to your
email you click on it that links back to
your browser I like this idea of if you
want access to data or Services the
endpoint server that you're connecting
to instead of you going hey I've got to
use no I got a password it's like well
hang on I'm going to go via another
Channel and I'm just going to confirm
via the back Channel this is app
actually you so it's two factors you've
got your browser you've got your email
email is a way of doing this kind of
sucks for a lot of reasons not least the
ones we're already talking about but I'm
sure you've seen you know you ever gone
to like Argos website in the UK there
are you know retailer Catalog Store and
you go on there and you're like hey I
want to find my nearest Argos store you
click that and it says this website
wants to know your your location
now this to me is where the balance
point is tipped over Argos would love to
know where I live they'd love to know
how much money I've got they'd love to
know what I'm interested in when is my
birthday who are my friends they don't
want to know where I am because I'm
moving all the time and that data would
be an absolute headache for them to
manage and so at this point it becomes
too expensive for them to manage that
themselves they just ask my browser
because my browser probably knows the
answer to that question let's take this
model stretch it a little further you go
onto Amazon and they get there and it's
like hey we want to sign in as Dylan
Beatty and access your delivery address
they don't need to know where I live I
know where I live my browser is allowed
to know where I live my uh internet
provider maybe my government is allowed
to know where I live we can use data
exchange based on these Services instead
of every company you ever do business
with having copies of all of your
personal data but then what about this
what about Amazon says hey I'll give you
a dollar for your browser history
well I don't know what you've been
looking at yeah is that worth something
and we're like yeah go on yeah I'll do
that I'll click allow the dollar goes
into my email account managed by my
internet provider and Amazon can see my
browser history they can see where I've
been and there are possibly people in
the audience right now going yeah and we
can do it it's going to be amazing and
we're going to Doodle using blockchain
no we are not gonna do it all using
blockchain
uh this is the only blockchain that I
would consider investing in
now
there is a lot of excitement at the
moment about uh distributed autonomous
organizations and daos and non-fungible
tokens and nfts and cryptocurrency and
all these kinds of things the metaverse
and a lot of the people who are talking
about this say they are working on web
3. now uh
I'm sure you all followed the uh the
massive hype in uh nfts non-funded
basically digital artwork
nfts were all the people on the ethereum
blockchain going we need to get more
money into this system because the smart
people have taken the money out the
other side already and we're left
holding the pretend internet dollars
that aren't actually worth anything
unless we get real dollars coming in
are there any stupid rich people in the
world and they look at Los Angeles and
they go ah
Come to Papa
and they're like who wants to buy a
monkey
for twenty thousand this this picture
cost twenty thousand dollars and what I
did is I right clicked it and I went
save as and now I have the monkey and
the best part is that I did that when I
was in Romania so I'm an international
art Thief so that's definitely worth
something a lot of people spent a lot of
real money on non-fungible tokens of
board apes and all kinds of stuff
um and yeah this was a mechanism
designed to get currency pouring into
the ethereum blockchain network so the
people who are holding ethereum could
use that money to cash out and disappear
before the whole thing Came Crashing
Down and did it well uh Jack dorsey's
first tweet
was uh sold for three million dollars
and then the person who bought it tried
to sell it for 48 million dollars and
the maximum bid they got was 280 dollars
now maybe it was just a bad week for
buying tweet by the way you know how to
sell a tweet for three million dollars
you find someone really rich and stupid
and you go
you want to buy a tweet
and I go all right and they give you
three million dollars and you go there
you go you have a Tweet now and you hope
nobody asks any questions that's
basically what it boils down to you know
um now there are some interesting ideas
around things like non-fungible tokens
but web3 is just kind of rattling around
in search of a definition uh the one
that I'm enjoying the most at the moment
is from Odin's talk this morning web3 is
a pyramid of dumpster fires
and there is a fantastic website run by
the awesome Molly white called web3 is
going great which is an aggregation of
news stories about uh fraud crime
bankruptcies people who have lost money
and in the bottom right hand corner of
Molly's website is a thing called the
griftometer and as you scroll down
web3isgoinggreat.com the griftometer
goes up
and every time it has a story that
someone lost a whole bunch of money it
counts up how much money they lost and
if you scroll back all the great things
that have happened on web3 as far as
April this year you get up to around
about a billion dollars that has been
lost
through things saying we are web 3 but
then you know the whole thing about web3
we don't know what it is yet
we think we know what web 2 is
because looking back with hindsight we
have decided that Web 2.0 web 1.0 was
the first web where you know smart nerds
with FTP access can make websites and
everyone else just has to shut up and
read them and then Web 2.0 was social
media platforms it was where you could
put your own stuff you could put your
pictures on Flickr you could put your
stories on Facebook you could uh have
live journals and Myspace and Bebo and
blogging and eventually Facebook and
Twitter and all these kind of platforms
it went from being the read-only web to
the read write web and in retrospect
people are sort of like yeah obviously
that was Web 2.0 but I was there when
they were building what became Web 2.0
I talk to people who are like yeah Web
2.0 is about micro formats that's what
it is little Snippets of XML embedded in
web pages so search engines can read
them no no Web 2.0 is the semantic web
it's about HTML tags that have meaning
Beyond just what the page look no no Web
2.0 is Ajax no Web 2.0 is RSS feeds no
it's not it's atom no it's XML no Web
2.0 is soap and rest apis and blogs and
customer reviews all the people who were
building these things all said they were
working on Web 2.0 and in hindsight yes
the ones who were working on uh micro
formats well they're still working on
micro formats that's web 4.0 now
um Ajax that's just part of the web now
no big deal like websites you can drag
and drop and they just load more stuff
that just turned out to be web 1.0 we
really should have put this in in the
first place right
um blogs atom feeds RSS feeds these were
all really big for a while and then the
social media platforms came along and
Consolidated it down I have deals with a
bunch of my friends that when they get
everyone to read blogs again I'll stop
posting on Facebook and no one's taking
me up on it yet and some of them just
kind of disappeared you know the
semantic web looked like a good idea but
the people who were working on this the
people who said they were working on Web
2.0 some of them were out to get rich
some of them were just trying to ride
the wave and get as much money as
possible but a lot of them they were
looking at the frustrations of web 1.0
and thinking how can we solve this how
can we use the technology and the
connectivity we have at our disposal to
make this better and make this more
inclusive and make people feel more
engaged with it and so I think 10 15
years time we are going to look back and
we are going to identify something let's
say yeah that was probably web three
that thing now I don't know yet what
that is but there are people I know who
are working hard for good reasons about
things like artists getting paid for
their work even if it's been distributed
digitally about people who want to
create more immersive collaborative
spaces than just sending slack messages
to your co-workers backwards and
forwards about people who are sort of
looked at the Revolution and remote
working and remote networking that's
happened during the pandemic and are
going yeah maybe there's an opportunity
here to do something more interesting
and yes there are words like metaverse
and nfts and blockchain bouncing around
all over the place because at the moment
that's where a lot of the investment is
happening if you want to do this stuff
and you want to get paid for it you
can't really sell anything yet so that's
what's going on but maybe
we are going to look back on web 3 as
the point where everyone went you know
what we're actually we're not going to
accept the terms and conditions anymore
we want to do the things we need to do
if you build a good product we will pay
you for it we want to get paid for our
work we want to get paid for our open
source software we want to get paid for
our music and our art and our movies and
let's come up with a way of doing that
that doesn't rely on multi-trillion
dollar corporations channeling all that
stuff backwards and forwards if you want
my money build a good product and I will
give you my money in order to use it but
until then give me an IP address and get
the hell out of the way
thank you
[Applause]